[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dimmed lighting is vlogger
gamer and creative one of the fastest
growing YouTube channels out there today
mark fischbach AKA markiplier markiplier
his unique approach to let's play style
videos has exploded all over the
interwebs earning him four and a half
million subscribers last year alone Wow
here's a clip of Mark playing the
insanely popular and very scary five
nights at freddys if I didn't want to
stay the first night why would I stay
any more than five why would I stay more
than his rise a youtube fame can be
attributed to many things one of them is
his amazing voice that clip didn't
really do it justice because he was
yelling a lot but you'll know what I
mean when you hear him in this biscuit
his voice will tickle your ears
tickle-tickle-tickle after spending some
time with mark we not only got to know
him better personally but we really
found this to be a case study in
connecting with your audience beyond his
amazing voice his success is also a
result of how open and even vulnerable
he is the viewers get more than just a
walkthrough of a video game they
actually get to know this guy on a
personal level because he isn't afraid
to wear his heart on his sleeve in this
biscuit we talked with mark about our
shared experience of swinging on vines
as kids
his emotional final moments with his
father the events that led mark to start
creating let's play videos and how I
read it post propelled him to internet
fame and why he chooses to share so much
of his personal life with his fans we're
really super excited to share our time
with Mark with you but first we want to
remind you that you can support this
show by checking out
lynda.com/rhettandlink
ly nd a.com ret a nd link whether you
want to take better photos or shoot
better videos learn programming skills
to develop your own mobile app or edit
your own video footage using Final Cut
Pro or premiere lynda.com offers
thousands of video courses to help you
get where you want to be it really is a
great site you can learn at your own
pace on your own terms and you can get a
free 10-day trial by going to lynda.com
slash rhett and Link and now the people
who just you know it isn't just like a
slideshow I mean this is people experts
telling you teaching you be experts in
these areas teaching new courses this
isn't like when you go ask your uncle
for advice you want to learn how to
whittle little go to lynda.com slash
rhett and Link and try it for free for
ten days on it listen 10 days for free
and if it doesn't work out you can go
back to your uncle your uncle will teach
you how to widdle now onto the biscuit
with markiplier I'm very open about my
emotions especially on my channel and
it's strange because I am a gaming
channel so all that content is gaming
oriented and it's in that aspect that I
push my channel but also with as with
many gaming channels they're not so much
about the games as they are about the
person and one of the things that has
taken me a long time to realize it's
just the kind of influence that I have
and also the kind of feedback I get from
my fans so the reason that I cried well
the most recent recent reason I cried
was for my 6 million subscriber video or
yes the fan the fan video yeah like they
made a music yeah yeah and it was it was
interesting because that hit me so hard
because the music that was played there
was a cover of a game that I played
which related back it was called to the
moon I don't know if you either of you
have ever played the game it's a rather
small indie game but it's about a dying
old man who wants to relive his life and
remake the choices that he's made and
the mistakes that he's made and going
back into his path
while really cool it was a very deep
game very good game too highly recommend
it very narrative-driven
but that's beside the point the song
from the climax of that game was what
was covered and when I heard it like
before I started recording my reaction
to it I it opened up and I heard like
the first word and I just went oh now
here they come Wow God so I got turned
on my camera so everything right so you
weep like a baby and you so you you knew
that you couldn't pre watch it you had
to get that so you if you were gonna cry
you can't have yeah you don't have to
recruit court your first reactor yeah
yeah I don't leave anything on the table
I'm all raw all the time whenever I
record my videos but that was actually a
promise that I made to that particular
channel because they made a 5 million
video for me and I didn't record my
reaction because I didn't have internet
at the time so I just watched it anyway
it was very touching but not like this
one was because when I'm even thinking
about it now it's kind of making me a
little weepy you're gonna see me cry
here but do it
no no but just it was the fact that I
saw so many of my fans in one place and
each of them took up maybe like a tenth
of a second but I still saw them and
they I I mean I knew they took the time
6 million times 10 seconds a tenth of a
second Oh God 10 seconds of peace I
would be incredible but yeah just the
fact that there were 649 people in that
video Wow 649 out of 6 million people
was such an astronomically huge
difference and yet in this video seeing
all those people in one really got to me
and when the song came on because the
game reminded me of my own family and hi
lost my dad when I was 18 and how like
in the game there was a question of the
brother and I have a brother that I care
very much for so the game hit me very
hard when I heard that music over what I
was seeing it was just it was too much
and it hit me really hard in my heart
and it just made me realize how lucky I
was to be where I was and the video that
I did before that where I cried again
like a little baby was for my actual
6,000,000 and I was or Noah's for five
million that's right every million
subscribers you cry up pretty much yeah
well because I'm honored I'm very very
on Shore
what happened but the reason that
particular one was so important to me is
because when I look back at all the
subscribers I have I remember the early
times and you guys probably remember the
early times in your channel when you had
a one-on-one conversation with a lot of
your fans and you were able to talk with
them and one of the things that hit me
hardest was I had recently been getting
a lot of emails from fans I've been
making a concerted effort to try to read
through some of the emails and it really
really hit me and I had to rerecord that
video like 10 times because I couldn't
get through it I was crying so much and
it was because I read emails of people
that were fans of me when I had just
started YouTube and it was from their
family members who said that my videos
helped them out in the last moments of
their life and that hundreds and
hundreds of fans who were there with me
in the beginning my channel are now gone
they died in the progress of me getting
to this point and they didn't care that
I was a huge channel and they didn't
care that I had 5 million subscribers
they cared that I was able to give them
some joy in their life when they were at
their last moments and that really
really resonated with me and and gave me
meaning because you know III recalled in
the video that because I talked about a
lot about losing my dad because I was
there and I was there through the whole
process and I was able to see what
happened to him and I visualized that
when I think of fans that I've lost
along the way I think of how how scared
they were and how they were surrounded
by family and those who loved them and
even though I'm not connected to them in
any way I don't know you don't know them
personally exactly if you have such a
connection and you know I certainly want
to explore your journey as the creator
to to bring along and amass such a such
an audience that is so connected to you
and it goes both ways I mean like you
get the impression you're not the only
one crying but like you said it's a
fascinating story that we want to unpack
and kind of step back through with your
dad and all these things you're
mentioning
because on the surface well it's just a
gamer gentlemen you're just a guy who
plays video games an outsider would say
yeah so I we do want to explore that and
we also want to explore a range of
emotions here you know we've talked
about wearing your heart on your sleeve
let's get back there but also another
emotion extreme pain I know have you
recovered from your 5 million scoville
experiment so yeah it was it was you
decided give us the backstory on this
hot sauce video um my fascination with
hot sauce started with hot pepper gaming
and I actually mentioned this last year
when I first met you I I loved the video
you did with the Ghost Pepper yeah how
you did you do the Ghost Pepper at the
same time of year yes you both did the
Ghost Pepper and I loved loved that
video and I started out with a habanero
so I didn't go as extreme but after that
I got this addiction and I found this
sauce that was about 2 million scovilles
and I accidentally did an ice cream
scoops worth because I didn't have
normal spoons so I might as well that's
a problem yeah that's a bad thing
you're only supposed to use a drop of
that but I use like a full teaspoon of 2
million Scoville hot sauce and it almost
killed me I like how your verb is you
used it you're not tasting you know
drying it you used it for views like we
did for something else it was a mixture
of I knew people wanted to see it but I
knew people didn't want me to do it and
that only pushed me to do it even more
just to like show them like ha you can't
control me I did it anyway ah crap and
what was that what sauce was the 2
million do you remember have these crazy
names yeah it was called the hottest
sauce in the universe version 2 so it
beat its previous version somehow it
upended itself yeah and this is the one
in the most recent no this was in the
previous one most recent 5 million yeah
it came in a coffin it was that bad I've
been in a store and seeing that yeah the
one that was waxey Gordon it was and
it's like called Satan's blood or
something I can't remember even what the
name was I don't even know if I read it
on camera but yeah some like that 2
layers of wax I had to get a knife and
just peel off and peel and struck it but
you took a smaller
and you went with just a fork yeah I
took two prongs of a fork and I dipped
it in and that's all I did it was just
as bad
like just those two prongs probably
equated to the same as what I did before
but I was mentally prepared for it so
even you did it because you had a head
cold
yes exactly man you wanted the views
yeah pretty much like I took a picture
of this like two months prior and people
are like don't do it for two months like
bringing it up every once a while I'm
just reminding me that I needed to do it
now I'm like fine screw it why not at my
lowest point when I'm sick and I feel
awful why not kick myself in the ass
because I am a true masochist in that
respect and I so so didn't want to do
that that morning and then I had the
idea and then I had to do it so were you
rewarded for your investment for my
investment of my sauce did it get rid of
your cold no it made it worse I felt so
bad after that because the same thing AB
the first time I did the two million odd
sauce
I felt fine thirty minutes after I did
the sauce yeah and two hours later it
dropped into my lower intestine
oh yeah like spongebob with the pie bomb
it dropped down and exploded and I
wounded up everything seizes up you go
into the fetal position right yeah on
naked on the bathroom floor yes that's
where I was and it didn't happen that
bad I was not naked because you because
it was a less lorem yeah it wasn't as
much so it kind of went away quicker but
I was still like oh no fell on ground
got trashcan was ready like I'm ready
for this I know what's up but you didn't
ratch did you no no I didn't throw up
that time oh it's horrible if you do
that oh it hurts worse coming up the
first time yeah when I was naked on the
bathroom floor yes absolutely I don't
know what the rating of this podcast is
so I won't go into vivid details of what
happened on that floor but can you can
just let us know okay I was naked on the
floor why are you naked I don't know
that's the weirdest thing because
somehow like I I was in the bathroom and
I was throwing up and I thought it would
feel better if I was not wearing clothes
cuz I was sweaty I was stable yeah yeah
yeah primal - you lose all discretion
when you're
in my Spain yeah if only I had a camera
would recorded it all put on YouTube for
the delicious views but no I was i
somehow it took off all my clothes and
decided that i needed to lay down and it
was so horrible because I thought I was
gonna die my phone was upstairs no one
else was there I knew like known in the
area you thought seriously maybe I need
a call like yes 9-1-1 yeah but I didn't
because you know because then you'd be a
story a news story yeah yeah I want to
die with some dignity
when you're throwing it up it burns
again oh yeah yeah did any look I was so
scared because I drank like a half a
gallon of milk
that'll do it to four and that probably
would made my stomach feel so bad and
then bananas are the key bananas are the
key yeah yeah yeah I will save that for
the next summer I need a couple of
bananas before and after and it really
helps I think you ate eight before the
Carolina Reaper I ate three before and
two or three after link ate one before
and none after because he doesn't like
bananas it'll fade thirteen hours after
we ate the Carolina Reaper which is two
million Scoville yes he was in the fetal
position he was not naked if he had a
gun [ __ ] I would've left the room so
crazy but then with this the five no he
didn't vomit but did it burn when you
pooped yes of course yeah that's like a
natural occurrence like with a habanero
yeah burn Ring of Fire
yeah oh man just the day after because
the day after was even worse cuz I had a
charity livestream the day after and I
don't know why I decided to punish
myself so severely the day before this
livestream but I only lasted three and a
half hours on the livestream but luckily
we hit our goal in like an hour and a
half so I was clear I could get out of
there but I felt so bad for so many
reasons and the goal was uh we were
raising money for the depression and
bipolar support alliance we're trying
fifty four thousand dollars was our goal
we raise $75,000 wow really cool awesome
let's get any process a little bit
before we go into your background
um you release to let's play videos a
day yes yes five or seven days a week
all days seven days a week seven days a
week and I mean do you have a backlog of
these things uh no actually um because I
like to stay on top of games that come
out more
and because there are less games to come
out it's hard to get the games that I
want to play now literally I could play
anything I wanted people would probably
still watch it but I like to stay recent
and play a very select band of games
because like people come to see me but
they also come to see the games like the
games got to be cool and with the way my
life works I have so many other aspects
that I'm trying to do because somebody
of mine some buddies of mine just came
in from South Carolina and they want to
do sketch comedy and I want to do sketch
comedy with them so I'm dedicating a big
chunk of my time working with them now
and because I where are you finding that
time usually in between everything else
in my life like eating and sleeping I
just sacrificed that and then I slot
that in there so you don't you don't
sleep not as much as I used to and
you're you're picking the right games
but every day you're playing you're
playing two sessions yeah or I mean do
you have to play more if you don't get
what you need kind of a thing yeah no no
that's totally possible I have a I have
a folder of games that people are very
curious about that I will never ever
post because they're either terrible
about terrible things I played like an
Isis simulator game and I don't even
know why I tried it was so terrible like
just so wrong in every way I couldn't
actually get through the whole thing who
makes these things it's just on the
internet like their indie game site and
game jams all the time where people just
spend 24 hours to make a crap game but
sometimes gems like surgeon simulator or
something like that will come out of it
and it'll be a great game that people
love to see because it's unique and
interesting so you gotta take risks and
be like okay I don't know what this is
about but maybe it's a joke that game
was not a joke like it was absolutely
not a joke at all not funny in any way
so never gonna get put up and there's a
lot of occurrences like that of jumpin
and then they have to chuck them and
then it's other again other times where
I'm recording like a 45 minute episode
because I'm playing a longer game or I'm
trying to get through it or I'm playing
a game that is an hour and a half and I
didn't know it was an hour and a half
going into it so you know it's always a
surprise in it so so a lot of the times
you are actually discovering the game
for the for the first time in the video
I mean this is your authentic experience
it's not let me check this game out let
me see
my angle is gonna be no no you very
rarely unless it's something that's pre
planned out beforehand which it hardly
ever happens I like to go into games
completely blind because that gets like
it gets authenticity out of me and I
never want to put up anything fake on my
YouTube channel like people will say or
look at my channel from a bird's eye
view and be like ah he sometimes like
fakes reactions or whatever but the
honest truth is that that's actually
just who I am and I'm trying my best to
make sure that everything I do is as
authentic as possible so what's your
day-to-day like uh schedule I mean today
I got up at 4:30 today because I
accidentally took a day off yesterday
and I had to record videos for my 8:00
a.m. release and my noon release but
unfortunately I had a meeting with like
an accountant and I had a doctor's
appointment this morning so I had to
cram all that in before 8 a.m. get that
done and up and then both videos yeah
both videos get them recorded done I
hoped and hoped that they were good
videos and they were what kinda so I
just threw them up and that was it this
is not how every day goes this is just
an example of what today happened to be
can you schedule them so they come out
at different times during the day yeah
you just throw them up eight and twelve
I think it's about eight and twelve
usually that's why I'm trying to do
since this year I tried to do that but I
I just spend a lot of time recording it
at anything because I don't have an
editor I'm a team of one I do all the
scouting for games I do the recording
and then I do the editing afterwards and
it's just kind of an endeavor but every
day it's an interesting adventure
because I built my life around this
schedule but I'm going to have to get
ahead of it at some point or else I'm
going to lose my mind and you keep it
pretty raw in terms of your not junk
cutting to just all the the best parts I
mean you're a lot of times you'll just
kind of play right through yeah not not
all the time I do for certain games but
yeah I like to give people more of a
more of a view of the game itself and
like the whole aspect of it because
people will say and I totally understand
for optimizing on YouTube you need to
have it a certain length
it can only be so long it can only be
the best bits you need to jump cut
everywhere to make sure that people are
always engaged and I do it to some
extent just if I'm totally silent
obviously cut them out or if I'm lost
I'll cut that out but I've always found
that people liked the whole experience
and because I'm very good at talking
like that's when my one skill I can talk
for hours on it if you let this podcast
run for like 14 hours and you left at
some point I would still be talking
about crap by the time you got back but
like since that's my skill I can do that
and I can go outside my life but people
do enjoy that but let's talk about the
talking you you've got like a radio
voice in your vlog it sticks its
ticularly goes tickling my ears right
now in this microphone and these these
headphones I definitely feel like maybe
this is a radio show and you're the host
and we're the guests I mean I don't want
to do a hostile takeover of your show
but if the fans demanded I sure will I'm
totally okay with that but no yeah I've
always been told that I had a radio
voice and it's the weirdest thing too
because in high school I was very shy I
never spoke but occasionally when you
have to do like public readings or you
have to read an expert in class I would
actually say something and people would
turn to me and be like oh my god you had
that voice this whole time and you
didn't do anything in a big yeah don't
look at me cuz I couldn't bring myself
to be anything outgoing in high school
did you have a really awkward voice
change because a guy with a voice like
yours usually there was a head part and
you know or was it gradual as far as I
know it came out of the womb sounding
like this so I can't really tell yeah
and what was the turning point to where
you became a talker if that wasn't in
high school was it when you started
playing video games I think actually
yeah because I've always been quiet in
whatever I do up until this point like
since I started doing YouTube I did it
as a way to force myself to talk every
day because originally when I did
YouTube I didn't want to do YouTube like
one of my biggest inspirations and I
actually got to meet him recently is
Freddie Wong because I loved loved the
videos that he did and I loved the
special effects special effects yeah
comic viral video yeah I love that
aspect of it and I love the creativity
behind it I watched all his behind the
scenes stuff and I was like I can do
this I can do this I didn't even know
how to hold a camera so I couldn't set
up a shot
I couldn't light it I couldn't get audio
correct
I couldn't do anything like that so I
was like okay what can I do
I've been told I have a good voice my
whole life what can force me to talk I
didn't even know what Let's Plays were
before I did them my brother is actually
the one that I credit me actually doing
Let's Plays because he watched them but
the weirdest thing is he watched
silently Let's Plays which aren't around
like just watching the game itself so I
was like oh wait I just didn't know that
his mute was on ER no no he just liked
seeing the game for the game like he
didn't actually like people talking
because back then there weren't these
energetic commentators there weren't
personalities talking over like me and
thought to be honest I wouldn't want to
talk over some of the games that he
watches just cuz the game itself is
actually very interesting and fun to
play but was it but when you started
doing it did you discover a hidden gift
of gab like that you could just fill
space with talking or did you can we
look back from the beginning of your
channel and see that it you develop the
muscles very developed because if you go
back you'll notice that I'm a sound
kinda similar but my voice is way higher
pitch and my pauses are awkward and I
can't come up with the things to say
like I didn't have a bag of tricks like
I kind to do now and even though I want
to take improv classes because I have
not tooken taken to any professional
training and I think that would lead a
lot to me being able to craft jokes
better especially when I'm talking but
over time it's all self taught and took
a lot of learning well describe the bag
of tricks
give us open the bag open the bag I
could hardly tell you a lot of dick
jokes just endless dick jokes yeah you
make a dick joke it'll be funny I'm sure
you guys as professional entertainer
comedians you know it's just a bag of
dicks but no I mean it's all about
letting your mind go into the game and I
think this is one of my best aspects
when I comes to me personally playing
games I open myself up to it I let
myself go into the world and I live as
best I can in the in the game and in the
moment so to speak yeah exactly so you
is you you forget the audience is there
or I'm always mindful that they're there
and you know I do the I look at the
camera whenever I can yeah but sometimes
and
I'll quote a game or I'll remember a
game specifically that I played it was
called presentable Liberty it was game
where you were locked in a cell for like
five days and you had no contact with
anyone you were just in the cell and it
was like a four foot by six foot cell
barren walls but the only way you
communicated with people was by them
sending you letters that slid in under
your door every once in a while and a
lot of people didn't have the same
response as I did but when I played the
game because I get so into it I felt
alone and I felt like my only connection
to another human being was through these
letters of people that I didn't know so
I had like this weird inner struggle
where I knew this was game and I knew
this wasn't real and I knew even if this
was real these people probably weren't
real and it was all staged because it
seemed fake but I cared because the
premise was that the entire world was
dying you committed to it yeah I
committed to entered it I felt like the
world was ending and I felt like these
people that I barely knew were dying and
I care so what was the result more
crying I didn't cry in that one like I
cried a lot of my videos but not all of
them but I had this existential crisis
like I literally was freaking out and I
couldn't handle the idea that I was
sitting in a room alone recording a
video playing a game where I was sitting
in a room alone yeah it was weird but is
that role play
were you wigging out were you
role-playing wigging out were you acting
I was really wigging out like I was
honestly truly having a crisis in my
mind and and like people were saying
like how can you respond that way it was
like because I live the games I play and
it doesn't always happen because games
can take me out of things very quickly
if they're the wrong type but this one
hit all the right buttons for me but
doesn't the line get blurred when you
are doing it for your own entertainment
but also for the entertainment of others
right especially when you develop this
bat to bag of tricks and the craft that
you have where okay this many million
people are watching me do this I mean I
I can say we relate to that there's a I
made myself I'm not being dishonest but
I'm not talking to link the way that I
would talk to him if no one was watching
oh yeah
yeah no that's totally true like if I
wasn't recording
I wouldn't be saying anything out loud
because I have no reason to but because
I've been good point ya seem crazy
otherwise but because I'm recording and
because it's become so autonomous for me
to record and talk at the same time I
can also get lost and I can start
talking to myself when there's no reason
I should be talking and how would you
describe that guy like if you didn't
know you and you saw you playing a video
game and you had to describe you to
someone else you would say this guy
talks like this acts like this but what
is your perception of yourself um I
would say this is a guy who is extremely
energetic and loud and I'm very
conscious of how I look from the outside
after I'm done recording but when I'm
recording I try to get into it but if I
was describing myself seeing myself
alone in the room I would question that
well I think a lot of people would I
think that's a natural question the
question wasn't going already yeah
exactly
performance yeah exactly because from
the outside perspective looking at that
on the inside and this is what I try to
remember when I get criticism like
people say like hey this is not real at
all and I'm like you're actually right
like it's totally not what would happen
in normal life or everyday Society if
you were playing a game alone but the
way it happens but you wouldn't be
watching it that's what yeah exactly
like if someone just like slack-jawed at
a screen like it wouldn't be all that
entertaining to watch although I know my
fans would probably still watch it I'm
still very mindful like I totally
understand like the question asking any
it's totally true it touches very much
on the conundrum that we as let's
players face like what is real what is
fake what is our personality and what is
our show you know and my goal is just to
like blend them together as much as
possible because when I see that like
when I see that I see someone who is
very energetic and probably not what
would really happen but when I'm in
there and when I'm recording nothing
else matters coz case in point the voice
you know we talked about your voice but
then there's you know you go into a
characterization you describe it oh yeah
yeah no III talk more animatedly it's
even happening with you like when you
first met me I've had hand in my pockets
yeah quiet voice but it
it's a weird switch that gets flipped
and it's like I know that I need to talk
and I know there are other people that
are gonna be listening to this so I need
to be careful about the words I choose
and I need to be mindful of what I say
and how I behave but also at the same
time like if you ask my friends how I
act among them you would kind of get the
same reaction just because I'm very
comfortable in doing that and I'm very
comfortable and when I play games with
friends probably like you could do a
shout and scream and I like yell at them
even though they may be quieter than I
am but I just love the boisterous aspect
of it being together on a couch and
playing games but what was the question
I I do this I ramble it I think you've
answered it I answered it oh yeah I
think it's fascinating your perception
of yourself yeah yeah it but I think
it's it's really a you're giving a
description of the artistry that that is
let's play and being good at it and
captivating an audience and being true
to yourself channeling the part of
yourself that's gonna connect with an
audience and walking the line between
performance in reality and I just think
that's fascinating especially for people
who aren't fans and again they're
Outsiders who are just thinking okay
yeah he just he commentates over over
plenty of videos you know Outsiders
myself included too
if you just until you experience it and
you become a committed fan it's just
it's kind of it's it's a different art
form that maybe at least I think this
description can help Outsiders
appreciate it yeah yeah and it's good
because I've never actually talked about
it from this perspective you guys are
given me because I know that you guys
probably don't watch my videos at all
and a lot of people don't watch my
videos or don't like my videos and I'm
totally okay with that I'm totally fine
Let's Plays are not for everyone they're
not the entertainment that a lot of
people need but once people I've noticed
this transition once people actually do
get into my videos and do get a phantom
they also have a switch that gets
flipped and they're like oh I see it now
I see why people like this and why I can
enjoy this and well so there's a there's
a part of what you're kind of getting at
which is authenticity and it's
interesting because
you have a desire to maintain
authenticity you're admitting that okay
guys I I'm not gonna be completely if
I'm a hundred percent authentic then I
would sit here slack-jawed staring at
the game
yeah that's not gonna be entertaining so
you are you know playing a role so that
people will be will get into it and want
to enjoy it but you're being yourself
and you've made this conscious decision
to insert your your life into your
channel in a way that other gamers have
it and I want to get to that but let's
get into that life a little bit now
getting back to your story
there's an interesting thing that we
have in common is that you swung on
vines in the woods as a child and that
was like one of our number one pastimes
growing up together oh we heard that in
your draw my life video when living in
Ohio you go into the forest back there I
lived in a house where there was woods
behind and back in Ohio you know you
don't get that out here you don't get
just woods that you can go into and get
lost for hours and not be kidnapped and
murdered we were just able to go out
there have the time of our lives break
all bones in our body and just be kids
out in the woods so we would go out and
we didn't have like tools to cut vines
so we would use sharp rocks and then
we'd find or you caveman on it yeah we
had machetes you had machetes yeah you
were allowed machetes as children I
don't think we told anybody okay bin
Greenwood I got hold of some machete his
dad's machete yeah we scavenged
everything we got old pocket knives and
we've once found a like a hand saw that
we tried to use but it broken shards
went everywhere so you had vines
everywhere yeah would you know they
would they would grow from the base
right and you and shot you would I
always thought they are my thing is you
know you kill the vine in order to then
enjoy enjoy then it's gonna you know a
month later you can't swing on that vine
anymore because you you chopped it off
at the base and you killed it but you
can't get a bucket of water and stick
the vine in the bucket of water in
between and alas weeks longer I don't
think we never see this children ever
thought of me and Ben did that you did
that but I'm Ben so well this is a
goodbye I mean yeah we had some epic
swings like over over the edge one of
the larger the biggest
injuries I ever got was and I think I
still carry it with me the scars to this
day of that's why I have back problems
is being mid-swing on one that went out
over a dirt road and it snapped at its
full height and I landed on my tailbone
from probably ten feet up oh yeah and
then he just he like rides around on the
ground screaming cursing and Ben and I
just kind of looked at him and laughed
I'm laughing now I don't know why kid in
pain hahaha did you ever get hurt oh not
me but my friend did like it's the same
thing Avenue at the apex of his swing he
snapped but he went into thorn bushes so
he was a lot better off than okay yeah
he just got cut up and cried like a baby
whatever did you get semi naked like
Tarzan or when you were eating like hot
peppers no no no nothing like that we
didn't neither yeah okay just checking
well we wouldn't tell you if we did yes
I have a lot of funny stories from those
times we once found of old VHS tape that
said I forget the name of it but it was
very obviously a porn tape okay and we
didn't understand how VHS is work we
thought they were film strips that you
could like pull out and see oh we like
tucked under our shirt and went back
home and we're like oh my god you found
it in the woods
yeah in the woods the woods randomly so
we went down the basement turned off all
the lights got some flashlights and
really Holly there's got to be crazy we
really ate at the time we didn't you
understand what porn even was except
that it was we weren't allowed to see it
so we pull all the magnetic strip out
like idiots we could just pop it in the
VCR but no we pull and we take a
flashlight and we shine it through
really yeah what wait a minute wait
can't see anything
oh no yeah we couldn't see a damn thing
because that's not how VHS has worked
they're magnetic strips and and there
was a VTR like literally for me oh it
was so close but I think it was like
dirt on the VHS and we didn't want to
get dirt in the VHS you know for some
reason and we were trying to create a
projector yeah yeah did not work that
way we were eight at the time okay we
did not think things through
did we and this is Ohio right yeah yeah
we would find pieces of porn in the wood
man-like magazine not hold magazines
like papers and parts of like trash pile
abandoned porn Abby
in porn as as adolescence oh that's
that's a shame
they probably discovered the Internet I
don't need this anymore free internet oh
okay how old you were
people are throw in the woods yeah maybe
they didn't like a particular girl on a
page just ripped it out threw it away
so paint a picture of growing up okay
all right growing up Ohio kind of rural
but you moved from Hawaii yes well yeah
to Ohio because my dad was in the
military and that's why I was on Hawaii
and that's why my brother's born in
Massachusetts
because I was only born 23 months later
exactly in Hawaii so we moved very
quickly from place to place and then he
left the military and apparently I was
wrong because I confirmed this just
recently we didn't go to Ohio right away
we went to someplace else that I don't
know to stay with family and then we
moved to Ohio so grew up in Ohio I had
no idea what Hawaii was like so I didn't
have any chance to miss it grew up in a
very very rural area you know in the
suburbs woods very isolated very fun I
thought it was greatest thing in the
world had no idea the scope of the world
until I went to Korea my parents were
getting divorced and that was very sad
and whatnot but it was probably for the
best they got divorced and then you know
we were spending a lot more time with
each parent and so I got the Asian side
from my mom and a lot of the Asian
experience and I got to understand what
that meant that I was half asian and
then I got my dad's side which was very
American you know he was as American as
it comes he's a military man very proud
of America and all that stuff so I got
two sides of that and I got a very broad
perspective early early on of people can
come from anywhere and people can be
anything but when I faced like in
schools and those type of towns you face
a little bit of racism if you're just a
little bit not white then that's just
enough to hate you yeah so some people
like we're very racist towards how bad
did that get it was more it was worse
towards my brother because he had more
Asian features growing up than I did so
he his own teachers would like openly
discriminate against
in class and belittle him and berate him
and mostly because they didn't like our
mother who was very very much the
typical Korean mother and if you know a
Korean mother you know what they're like
and she was exactly like that and and
that bled into our lives but as we grew
up it got less and less I don't know if
because the world became more
understanding or just because we grew
more into our white features or
something like that but you know it
always stuck with us a little bit you
know if you grew into your white
features I think so yes I think that
actually is a thing that can happen it
became more white in a weird way yes
actually I would honestly say that's
true because me and my brother looked
very similar when we were kids and we
both look very Asian but people who meet
me today it's like a 50/50 chance if
they think I'm just pure white or if I
if I have any Asian in me they're
surprised you know it's a big toss-up
but early on it was much more distinct
but that didn't stop like Asian jokes
and whatnot but I don't really care
you know it's solely fine racism happens
I'm not saying that I I need to be a
charity case just because I had racism
and it's affected me it really didn't
but your mom took you to Korea yeah
that's what a stripper like you were
living there uh we took trips for a few
weeks at a time because we had family in
Korea she was the only daughter of seven
that moved to America because my
grandparents on that side actually have
a very interesting story they were
originally in North Korea before the
Korean War and they were right on the
border of China
like way way way up north and they came
from a very wealthy well-off family they
had everything they needed my grandpa
had a beautiful wife and lots of
inheritance and then he heard from his
buddies in the American armies that was
going down like things were getting bad
so he basically said to his family like
if you won't come with me I am leaving
and they didn't come with him so he left
everything behind my skids everything he
only took the wife he had no kids at
that time he just actually married he
grabbed his wife my grandmother and ran
down south on foot all the way down to
Seoul Korea which is where they live
outside of or they lived outside of
Seoul Korea and that's just what
happened they cut off all ties and
year later war was broken out borders
drawn and he never saw his family again
Wow yeah just for the rest of his life
he never saw a single member of his
family so you were going back and
gaining an appreciation for this stuff
with your haven't your parents haven't
split up mmm yeah yeah because that gave
me another world view to like oh I guess
relationships don't last forever or
something like I don't know if that's
bled into my life now probably has in
some way and I have deep-seated issues
about that but I think in a way it was
actually better for me to see that early
on and understand it because I've always
been inquisitive and I like I've always
been trying to appreciate things from a
whole view and that's why I tried to do
with my channel today I try to
appreciate everything that I see from a
whole view and look at it from all
angles because that's why I look at
myself and I'm able to appreciate the
perspective of someone doesn't like
Let's Plays they can see that I'm you
know it I wouldn't do this normal
circumstances but that all led into me
growing up in this rather diverse rather
multi-location childhood with your so
you were it was shared custody or you
did you live with your dad lived with my
dad mostly which was actually unusual
yeah how is that how that decision made
um well I actually I don't know the
specifics of it I was only put in like
brought into court it like once or twice
just of like how old were you that no I
can't actually remember maybe I was
younger than that maybe this was like
seven but in the end it was just like my
mom thought it would be better if I live
with my dad
late years later she would regret it and
then she'd accept it because she thinks
like nowadays if I have my mom she
thinks that I was better off for growing
up with my dad because he taught me he
was like the greatest dad in the world
like he taught me such to keep such an
open mind about things in I wish I could
have asked him more stuff down the road
after I had really grown up and found
myself when I was like 22 is about the
time that I really started discovering
myself I wish I could have asked him so
much more but that's in the past I can't
do that when did when did he it sounds
like you were really close to him oh
yeah absolutely yeah he was he was the
smartest man I knew in the most
understanding man I knew and probably
still to this day like I don't know
person who was more wise and more and
had a better perspective
davonne the entire world than my dad and
it sucks because I would want to ask him
so many things but what was the
circumstances of his passing oh he had
cancer like and he'll he'll only he
would have only blamed himself because
he was a smoker for 46 years he started
when he was 14 and even though he quit
like eight years before he actually got
cancer you know he kind of accepted that
I he did this to himself so I really saw
was emphysema or lung cancer lung cancer
like straight up lung cancer that spread
to a few different places that it was
how are you when he was diagnosed I I
think I was 17 I I just turned ya know I
was just about to turn 18 so I think it
was 17 when he was diagnosed and that
was really hard for me to take at that
point just cuz you know the person who I
understood as the person I wanted to be
was dying and I saw him waste away
basically from the very outgoing very
strong character that he was to and
anyone who has experienced anyone with
cancer would know this to just how they
waste away as a person and eventually
just kind of fade away and did not the
person that you remember okay and how
long of a process was that it was it was
over a year but that year went by so
quickly just to see it all happened I
was just going into college to which
really took a toll because I had this
college relationship or high school
relationship that ended before college
and that's totally fine
like we moved on no relationship
survives really from that perspective
but that on top of my dad was suffering
through school and I didn't perform as
well as I did and then I got bad grades
and my dad was disappointed in me and I
felt so terrible because look I wish I'd
tried harder and then I made a concerted
effort to do that but just seeing the
process by which my dad kind of you know
just drifted away from the person I knew
but still what was the final you know
how did it resolve were you there I was
there yeah I was there when he when he
died it was a very scary time and you
know I was lucky enough to be there when
he died even though it was very scary to
see I would always rather be there in
times like that and face it head-on then
try to run away from it and not see it
because
you know you need to you need to be
there because it's another experience in
your life that you need to get
perspective on because one of the things
that iíve been through myself is I have
a tumor I had a tumor you know about
three-and-a-half years ago and it it
along with that made me realize that I'm
going to die someday I know this I know
full well that I'm going to die I know
full well that it's going to happen
probably when I least expected and at
the least convenient time in my life and
because of that that very much motivates
me to do whatever I can now here and now
I need to be the best person I can
because I won't have enough time no
matter what I do no matter how I
approach my life I will not have enough
time and no one will no one on this
earth will have enough time to do what
they need was your tumor cancerous no it
was a very rare tumor called a ganglion
neuroma which basically means it's a
tumor made of nerve cells it can become
cancerous but this one was not so I'm in
the clear as far as that goes
I seem to have a clean bill of health
thus far and medical science only
improved so I may not die of something
along those lines but how did your
account of the experience of your dad
passing impact your trajectory um
actually that's that's a really good
question because when he passed I was
kind of in a toss-up a won at what I
wanted to do in college like the idea of
being a youtuber wasn't even a thing
back then maybe the first fledgling
youtubers were just starting but they
weren't getting paid for it so it hadn't
even crossed my mind I just knew that
whatever I did I needed to try to do it
a hundred percent so the year after my
dad died the first quarter was very hard
but I tried very hard in school and I
did very well and I got a very good job
and I tried my best at that job even
though it was the most boring job that
I've ever had in my life I tried very
hard and I wanted to do the best I could
in what I did so I push myself and even
though I fell off the horse sometimes
and I got a big World of Warcraft stint
like that consumed a lot of my life
because games have always been a big
part of my life I've always been a gamer
I always wanted to play games so that's
just kind of how it went and then I
rolled forward with that until I was
kicked in the ass with the tumor and
also before that I got laid off from my
job and then it's just kind of compound
into this moment where I had this
self-reflection and this is what I meant
when I said before that I discovered
myself when I was like 22 it was after
all of the compounded in all this stuff
happened to me and all like I had this
struggle with why even bother you know
everyone has that moment who has pushed
past it or let it consume them they have
had the why even bother moment and I
fortunately enough push past it and a
lot of people may not be able to and a
lot of people try really hard to do that
and by doing what well that's the thing
you don't know what you what is gonna
make you push past it and get the will
to keep moving forward or get the will
to do something different or take a risk
but it's just the the only thing that
question needs to be answered is that I
will push past and then everything else
is like I don't know how I don't know
what I'm gonna do I don't know why I'm
even deciding to do this I just need to
do something so I tried writing I tried
making a webcomic I tried art I dropped
out of engineering to pursue like go
indoor at school and then I dropped out
of that cuz it wasn't working for me it
didn't feel like what I need but I tried
so many things I didn't find what I
wanted to do until like way way later
after this but I had the realization
before I did YouTube like after all that
went down I had the realization and I
knew that I don't know what I want to do
the weirdest thought that I've had
recently was that the some of the
greatest artists or people that have the
greatest potential to be incredible
artists are not artists you know the
people that have an incredible potential
to be athletes or stuff like that are
not athletes
they chose something else because that
appealed to them or some circumstances
put him in that situation they didn't
know that they could because they didn't
try and that's not a discredit to them
they weren't may have been in the
situation but I knew that I was good at
something I had to be I had to be great
at something and I wanted more
desperately than anything in the world
to have something that I could say that
I was great at so it was more for you
was it more about saying finding the
thing that
you were great at or with finding the
thing that you enjoyed the most both I
wanted both like it sounds selfish to
say I wanted it all but I really did cuz
I wasn't I wasn't at the point where I
was trying to find what was fun I was
trying to find what was most satisfying
like to me as an individual I didn't
even care about making money off of it
really because III I was a college kid I
was used to very limited budget I didn't
come from a rich background I actually
had a very poor background like a child
had grown up like I didn't have
Christmas presents for many Christmases
because we didn't have the money for it
or one night and that's totally fine but
you try so you tried a whole bunch of
stuff yeah yeah yeah all the time you
were very passionate about gaming but
you didn't connect those dots until a
while later yeah yeah but you eventually
did it obviously so how did that happen
well that happened because what like I
said my brother brother my brother knew
about Let's Plays and when I was looking
at that I was like can they even make
money off of it yeah whatever I'll try
cuz I didn't know I didn't know that
they made money and I picked horror
games because I saw this one compilation
video which was like a whole bunch of
people playing amnesia the Dark Descent
and I never played the game before and I
never known about the game but I watched
that video and it was the funniest thing
I've ever seen to see people scream like
little girls in the face of these
monsters and I said like yes I want to
make people laugh with my screams of
Terror because that is the funniest
thing I've ever seen and I did that and
that's what I did
and I thought it was great and no one
watched it really just some of my
friends subscribe to me and then I made
a compilation because that's what I
wanted to do that's what I saw I saw a
compilation that was really cool and I
thought I'd make a compilation and I
didn't even know how I didn't even know
how to cut things together I didn't even
know how to make subtitles so I had to
like struggle and learn like just how to
put words on a screen was just a
challenge for me and then I did it I
spent like two days straight no sleep no
food just straight-up making this video
and I was like yes it's done I showed it
on my brother and my brother laughed and
I was like goal accomplished everything
I set out to do is done my brother
laughed at this it made him laugh I am
so happy so I threw it up on my youtube
channel and I knew that no one was
really watching it and
somehow someone found it and someone
posted it on Reddit and oh it made it to
like number three in videos our videos
it made it to number three and I was
sitting in the middle of I remember I
was sitting in the middle of church then
my my mom dragged me to her very very
pompous big church so we went there and
I was just sitting like bored out of my
mind because no one is excited to church
and I looked at my phone and my emails
were just blowing up how many views are
we talking about on that video it got in
back then it got a hundred thousand
views and for a channel that had no
subscribers that was unbeaten yeah not
uh twenty probably 2012 no it was 2012
okay yeah so to me that was unheard of
like I couldn't fathom that many people
and I it was my first exposure to
comments that was not your first video
but it was your first college yeah it
was first compilation I've made like a
twelve part series on amnesia and then I
made that video so it was like my 13th
or something video and now I I read
through every single comment and I got
the same thing that I get today like oh
they're students faking this little what
a bunch of bull and what this guy is the
worst and some but some people were like
this is really funny and that resonated
with me and said did you think okay this
is the key I've got to compile oh yeah
no you're dead right I thought like oh
this is what I wanted to do I gotta do
this so like every week I would play a
game and then compile it and a play a
game and compile it highlight reel yeah
exactly highlight reel stuff and I
thought that was really cool because it
condensed everything that I did four
hours into one cool video and people can
enjoy it but I never got the same
response
so I'd never got posted to Reddit again
and it never got the big blowing up and
I was like oh man I thought they were
good enough but it wasn't that they were
good enough it was just the timing thing
in the look but was it for something to
blow up on reddit was it a specific
speculation about by you being nuts or
something I mean it for something to
really resonate on the video subreddit
mm-hmm there had to have been something
more than it was just this guy's funny
right no that was that was it that was
it and I was so honored because the the
good
comments on that were like people
actually left and it wasn't it wasn't a
cynical speculation of something that no
no no I didn't intend that wasn't it at
all okay good it was pure and simple
people found it entertaining and that's
what set a spark in me and even after
the other videos didn't get the huge
response there were people that saw my
first video that subscribe to me and
we're now commenting on a regular basis
saying like dude you're funny your voice
is great and I was just like oh my
goodness
people like the things I do this is what
I liked like cuz you liked this I I
heard you say in one vlog that at first
you wanted to make comedy sketch videos
yeah was that book so was that before
you started the let's play or was that
in tandem those before yeah because you
were seeing successful youtubers in that
genre or because of some other reason I
thought it was just really cool I only
wanted to do what I liked and I liked
those videos so this is one of the
things I tried before I did you know
Let's Plays I tried this for months I
tried it I spent the last of my money
that came in on a tax refund on a t2i
I didn't even have a microphone with it
just did you thought hey it's got
onboard mic why not use that um a little
green screen that I stupidly it was a
blue a blue green green screen it will
fold that one and I would take it
outside in the green grass and the blue
sky and I would just put it up like
this'll work right and I had no idea
what I was doing so those are sketch
videos yeah yeah yeah they were sketch
videos and I made three of them or I
filmed three of them and I had no idea
how to edit them together get special
effects in there I have no idea I was at
a loss and I looked at it was like this
is gonna take months and months of
trying and effort and when I'm done with
it it might not even be good and I still
did it like I still I still tried and
then I tried and tried and then I was
just like ah man but you know that they
didn't get finished
no no they did not get finished because
I kept hitting my head against a wall
like sleepless nights trying to figure
it out cuz I love solving puzzles but
this puzzle I I kept coming to the
conclusion that these people had been
doing this for years like they've
learned College how to do special
effects I don't know and so in the
middle of that process that frustration
and your brother is the one that kind of
says
yeah we want you to try something like
this or at least points out let's play
videos yeah that's when yeah and that's
what I was like I could do that it'll be
good practice for my voice so when you
started getting that initial response
people coming to your channel people
commenting reading every comment mm-hmm
how did because this is a subprocess
that happens without you even knowing it
but as you look back now how did the
initial reactions from fans the initial
comments shape who markiplier is today
it was everything like at that point the
fact that people were even talking to me
was unknown I was the kind of kid that
had Facebook but never talked to friends
I don't text my friends proactively so I
lived a very isolated life like without
people actually saying anything to me
and in that way they didn't expect
anything out of me and so I didn't drive
myself to try to impress other people
and then when suddenly comments were
rolling in both positive and negative
like I got tons of hate in the beginning
which was totally fine I can ignore hate
all all all day long but positive
comments of people saying they really
enjoyed it and they were like but you
could do this differently and I took
that to heart like like I want to see
more of this or I want to see these
videos or or I'm well what kind of
things really saying we're at the time
minecraft was big so if you were like oh
could you do a Minecraft video on the
people you know I hate minecraft or it's
like and I was like oh one or the other
what which do I do so I actually created
another channel and called it markiplier
- and made minecraft videos and people
loved it like I was like oh my god
people love this and then I went through
the unfortunate thing where youtube
actually banned my adsense account first
one reason or another I have no idea to
this day and that was Omaha on your
second channel on both like it was the
same adsense again and I almost stopped
youtube right then in there when was
that that was in like the first month
and a half of my channel I almost would
not have been here if I just kept just
said okay YouTube banned my adsense
account okay you don't know the reason
but it had something to do with less
play and rights of yeah yeah I think so
yeah because for some reason I wasn't
monetizing my main channel videos but I
thought minecraft it even said in its
terms of use you can monetize videos of
this on YouTube so I thought okay I
guess this is okay but I kept getting
emails that were like do you have the
to monetize this and I would be like I
think so and i quoted Minecrafts terms
of use and i put it up there and so I
think it was just constant I got so many
email responses like these are all
automated in the right when everything
was automated and I think I flagged the
system enough that it was just like this
guy must be doing something wrong here
get rid of him and I was just done like
that
I tried calling everyone I could I tried
to ask and everyone I could I couldn't
get in touch with anyone I almost gave
up I was so heartbroken because the
thing I wanted to do that I could have
possibly done as a career which I
wouldn't have even made money off of
enough to live off of for months months
months down the road but it was just the
door was shut and YouTube itself did
this and I was like so disheartened what
was the resolution I just made another
channel I was I was two steps away from
getting signed under a third channel
yeah a third channel and what called
markipliergame and that's why my channel
is called markup on our game right now
and not markiplier because I can't use
markiplier
it still exists and then you re uploaded
old videos downloaded every single video
I did and I had done about a hundred and
fifty at that point cuz I uploaded five
videos a day back then when I was first
going I was like everything every every
single second of my day was recording
videos and uploading them it was it was
amazing and so how did you make how did
you make the decision at what point did
you say I'm going to insert myself
personally not just the gamer mark but
I'm gonna cry no what was the first
video where you kind of went into that
that vlog I knowed I had always put my
heart and soul into it but I never
really connected deeply it was only when
I went to comic-con San Diego in 2012
for the first time with my brother
because yeah he has a very successful
webcomic by the way that's why I could
guys write yeah two kinds yeah yeah it's
a really really great webcomic as it's
been online for a long time but he got a
booth at comic-con San Diego so I went
with him just because the company that
he works with was nice enough to get me
an exhibitor badge which I was totally
grateful for but when I went there I had
maybe 2,000 subscribers this was on my
new channel mark of our game I had 2,000
subscribers I didn't expect to see a
single person there that knew me and
four people came up
and new me like I didn't even know the
the astronomical odds of two thousand
people all over the world subscribed me
and for people at comic-con came up
inside me and I saw the real people I
saw who they were they were actual
people that enjoyed my videos and
actually knew who I was and that blew my
mind and I said to myself holy crap
every single person that is subscribed
to me is real and is their own person
and it has their own hopes and dreams
and has their own life that they live
and they take a small moment in that
life to watch my videos so you decided
to talk directly to them and vlogs yeah
and last time I did that as soon as I
got back I made one of the first vlogs I
ever did and I just stood in front of
the camera I was awkward as hell I
didn't know what I was doing and I was
like hello this is me I'm going to tell
you about this person that is me and
then that's just when I started doing it
in and what was the response what do
people say people loved it like people
loved like seeing me in person and
seeing who I was cuz I didn't even have
a face cam back then like I did all
voice yeah all voice and people didn't
know who I wasn't people were very
surprised to see me people had critiques
on how I was people said I was cute and
you're Korean but you got a lot whiter
yeah at that point I was very very
slowly
7030 white Kareem you grew into your
whiteness comment yeah you know no one
had ever seen your face yeah yeah and it
was just it was a really really cool
timing did you get any negative response
so cuz because it's it's striking I mean
the way you've mixed the way that a
vlogger like a guy like Tyler Oakley
yeah the way that he will connect with
his fans and it's like his brand is
connecting with his fans you know he's
not playing games
he's just connecting with his fans right
but you brought that same vibe and I
have to assume that in the way that the
gaming world interprets things and the
way they think about things there had to
be some negative reaction to that we
don't want to hear about your life or
yeah I get that all the time like even
today like they'll be calm and sort of
like what is this I only signed up for
games why are you doing vlogs and like I
appreciate your view there but I don't
care like I want I've always set out to
do this and connect with people because
that is the only
reason I'm here is because of the people
that are subscribed to me and I always
need to pay respect to that facet of my
channel do you think that is a big
factor in the astronomical growth of
your channel I mean you say and going
from a thousand subscribers just a few
years ago six million subscribers now
how many of those over the past year um
over the past year I I think I only had
about 1.5 million this time last year so
yeah four and a half million in a year
four and a half million over the past 12
months
how did that happen what do you
attribute that to uh I think I would say
the fact that I directly connect with
people people don't sort of locks III
don't think it's solely to the vlog yes
I I play games that kind of lead into a
certain brand and five nights at freddys
don't get me wrong
took off like crazy and really grew my
channel 25 million views oh yeah 26
million I think actually now it's okay
guys that's just to correct you but like
get it growing it'll be more ya when
five nights at Freddy's 3 comes out like
it's gonna be nuts but and that really
did help and I'm very grateful that I
was lucky enough to be on the forefront
of that but I think what really has kept
people here and what I see a lot if we
sent people on the internet outside of
YouTube say oh I know of this guy I
don't like his videos but I like the
person and that's all that I ever care
about like I want people to know who I
am and not the games I play cuz I will
play games like for as long as people
want me to play games cuz I love playing
games but in the end in the end so long
as people know who I am as a person and
see that I try my damnedest to do what
is right at all times that's what
matters now one of the things you said
in your draw my life video is that and
you made that you know when you had less
than a million subscribers but you
characterized what YouTube had given you
the opportunity you tube had given you
as if it had almost given you a new
purpose on the other side of that
success now you know passing 6 million
subscribers
being able to raise money for these
charities on a regular basis and pushing
half a million dollars
what ro Qing that right we passed that
I'm pretty sure yeah what would how
would you react if all of it was taken
right now so you go back home and you to
you you can never upload another another
YouTube video like this career is taken
from you I think I'd be okay cuz I I
have long thought about the fact that we
as youtubers run the risk of YouTube
going away
you know it could just go away at any
day and I think there would be a lot of
people that would be upset that I
wouldn't be able to upload videos
anymore but me as a person I would want
to pursue other avenues like those
things that I tried before YouTube that
didn't work I would want to keep trying
different things and see what happens
and it may lead to the point where I am
NOT in the public eye in any way I am
totally alone I'm working a nine-to-five
at some mill somewhere that could happen
like that could be where it leads but
I'm not gonna stop trying to find what I
enjoy and what fulfills me more fulfills
me than joy well we're not gonna take
away your YouTube access I mean I hope
not do you have that power well maybe I
was just based on his answer oh that's
how I was gonna make my decision I was
gonna pull the plug we do not have that
power and I don't think that's gonna
happen so given that what plans do you
have let them give us a nugget more
sketch-comedy more exploring different
avenues because gaming allows me you
know the ability to do different things
and launch different things and try
different things it's just a matter of
time at this point are we gonna see
those on your channel yeah all on my
channel like likes cats comedies music
videos I've got a whole bunch of stuff
that I can't wait to do we're filming
something tomorrow actually and I'm very
excited for it it is five nights at
Freddy's related but you know that's
just because my buddies have this idea
and it's actually a really cool idea so
well look forward to it and we we really
enjoy getting to know you
it's time for you to sign the roundtable
of dim lighting oh boy
thanks for coming in man
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with markiplier let mark know what you
think of our conversation by tweeting at
him his Twitter handle is markiplier
it's like multiplier but mark instead
use hashtag ear biscuits we really do
appreciate it when you give feedback to
our guests that's helpful as well as
leaving a review on iTunes those things
are both really helpful to us I'm
fascinated by a guy like Mark I love him
we talked to somebody who has helped to
define a genre not that he and he
obviously is he didn't invent let's play
videos hehe but he's not defining the
genre
he's refining the genre yeah I have a
feeling that more and more let's play
guys are going to start being vulnerable
if not crying there I say crying in
their videos because he you're right you
know this is the kind of thing that you
turn a genre on its ear a little bit cuz
you've got these gamer guys who are not
necessarily known for being emotional
guys or definitely not being that open
in fact the genre was defined for a long
time by guys who never showed their face
and then you got guys showing their face
and they're all the guys to show their
faces are getting popular PewDiePie fill
in the blank now you got guys who are
showing their faces and crying and their
faces are crying their faces are crying
and you know I'm not I'm not poking fun
at mark I mean he's a genuine guy he's
really really good at what he does and I
like him and he knows how to connect
with people and you know I applaud him
for going on instinct and really
refining a genre just like you said he's
he's got a knack for connection and
there's so much to learn from that
because the question s 'full by the
question of him that you should
calculate right something that I doubt
is what I wanted to get it's a
reflection of who he is and he wants
people to know the real him if he you
know but doesn't the producer in you
because I know the producer in me wants
to think also that well he could also
know that this would
was going to work and so we started
doing it I don't actually believe that
but there's this the producer in the
back of my head is like well if he's not
doing it at least somebody else is gonna
start doing it and so now you're gonna
have guys who are feigning emotions for
subscribers
you've got people eating weird stuff
rhett and Link or two of them that's us
for subscribers what about people crying
drivers the audience is smart I mean
they're a good judge of authenticity and
character they'll know if it's fake you
know for a guy like Marc I mean look at
all the money he has raised for charity
it's amazing you know it's challenging
for me personally and professionally to
see a guy who instinctively put so much
of his time and effort into channeling
his audience and empowering them to to
give to something that there's no
there's no direct tangible benefit for
him I think that's awesome and like I
said I you know I kind of privileged to
have gotten to know the guy my only
disappointment is we didn't make him cry
today
you know but we made a song biscuit with
him we did that's pretty cool sorry
great if you haven't if you haven't
checked that out on our good mythical
morning youtube channel our song biscuit
we wrote a song about five nights at
freddy we did and he can't he kind of
brought us up to speed on that I would
prepare that guide in it I'm preparing
for the judgement that is going to be
unleashed on us for writing a song about
five nights at Freddy's I'm a little
scared we usually don't go into those
areas that we're not really experts on
but we felt yeah we kind of because she
was he was there he was the Sherpa for
five nights at freddys yeah so thanks
for that mark and thanks to you for
listening and supporting the show we
appreciate it and of course we'll be
here in your ears next week baking a
biscuit
[Music]
[Music]